usa el método de sustitución para
encontrar xy para encontrar james y aquí
tenemos dos ecuaciones y es igual a
menos 5 x + 8 y acá abajo 10 x + 2 y
igual a menos 2 y el método de
sustitución en general es que si tenemos
una variable en función de la otra la
podemos meter adentro de la otra
ecuación y es justo lo que voy a
utilizar porque aquí me dice que james
tiene que ser igual al menos 5 x más 8
por lo tanto en lugar de esta y voy a
meter menos 5 x más 8 sustituyendo la de
la primera ecuación porque yo sé que se
tienen que cumplir ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente por lo tanto vamos a
ponerlo aquí en lugar de voy a poner
menos 5 x + 8 y como la primera ecuación
es cierta entonces vamos a sustituir el
valor de y utilizando la información que
me dice la primera ecuación entonces
vamos a meterle aquí y vamos a ver qué
es lo que me queda y si yo enchufó a
james igual a menos 5 x más 8 en la
segunda ecuación me va a quedar 10 x + 2
porque pero en lugar de james voy a
enchufar menos 5 x más 8 más 2 queremos
multiplicar ayer pero llévale menos 5 x
+
- 5 x + 8 esto tiene que ser igual a
menos 2 y bueno después voy a distribuir
este 2 por todo lo que está dentro del
paréntesis entonces ya tengo una
ecuación con solamente una incógnita y
que me va a quedar 2 x menos 5 y 2 por 8
2 x menos 5 x me va a quedar menos 10 x
10 x 10 x 2 x 8 es 16 entonces más 16
menos 10 x + 16 esto tiene que ser igual
a menos 2 y bueno aquí tengo 10 x menos
10 x estos dos se pueden cancelar estos
dos se pueden ir
estos dos me dan 0 por lo tanto los voy
a tachar y voy a hacer como si no
existen y me queda que 16 es igual a
menos 2 y 16 es igual a menos 2 esto no
tiene sentido qué pasó aquí qué pasó con
este sistema de ecuaciones y cuando
llegamos a resultados de este estilo tan
bizarros resulta que tenemos un sistema
inconsistente 16 nunca es igual a menos
2 por lo tanto esto es un resultado
inconsistente y este sistema de
ecuaciones es inconsistente a qué me
refiero a que no existe ninguna
james que cumplan estas sus ecuaciones
simultáneamente dicho de otra manera
estamos hablando de dos rectas paralelas
es más déjeme gráfica de los para que te
des cuenta a que me estoy refiriendo
fíjate bien aquí tengo un eje de las
equis aquí tenemos me quede leyes y la
primera ecuación ya está en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen así que
vamos a criticarla
5 6 7 y 8 entonces por aquí corta en mi
eje de leyes y tiene una pendiente de
menos 5 por lo tanto va hacia abajo con
una pendiente de menos 5 vamos a suponer
que esta es la gráfica de la primera
ecuación ahora mi segunda ecuación no
está en la forma pendiente ordenada el
origen por lo tanto vamos a despejar
allí entonces tengo 3 x + 2 y esto es
igual a menos 2 y ahora voy a restar 10
x de ambos lados de la ecuación de tal
manera que me queda que 2 y es igual a
menos 10 x menos 2 y ahora voy a dividir
todo entre 2 entonces me queda que ya es
igual a menos 5 x menos 1 dividiendo
todo entre 2 y date cuenta que tenemos
la misma pendiente es una recta paralela
solamente que esta recta corta en menos
1 son rectas paralelas fíjate bien
tenemos la misma pendiente solamente que
una distinta ordenada el origen y
entonces
son dos rectas paralelas y las rectas
paralelas nunca se intersectan por eso
se dice que este sistema es un sistema
inconsistente cuando llegamos a algo de
la forma 16 es igual a menos 2 o una
constante igual a otra que no son la
misma entonces hablamos de un sistema
inconsistente y por lo tanto podemos
concluir que no existe una xy una gemma
que satisfagan a ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente no tenemos solución
alguna